>> SINCE YOU ARE THE ELDER
STATESMAN OF THE FRANCHISE, CAN
YOU GIVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT
PEOPLE HERE THINK ABOUT THE SUNS
AND THE CHANCE TO WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP, THE FANS?
DEVIN: WHAT THEY THINK ABOUT THE
SUNS?
THINK IT IS THE BABY HERE.
IT IS THE ONLY PROFESSIONAL TEAM
THAT IS PHOENIX.
EVERY OTHER TEAM IS ARIZONA.
THE PHOENIX SUNS IS THE BABY
FRANCHISE, AND THEY LOVE IT WITH
A PASSION.
WEARING THE SHIRT FROM 1993
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK IT STARTED AROUND THAT
TIME, TO WHEN THEY DEVELOP THAT.
YOU HEAR PEOPLE TALK -- I
REMEMBER WHEN I WATCHED CHARLES
AND THEM.
YOU HEAR THOSE STORIES AT ALL
TIMES.
SEEING THE PASSION IN THEIR EYES
WHEN THEY ARE TELLING THE
STORIES, AND EVEN BEING AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE BARREL FOR THE
PAST FIVE YEARS, I AM STILL
SHOWING UP AND SHOWING LOVE.
SHOWS THE TYPE OF LOVE FOR THE
TEAM.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE HAD
INTERACTIONS WITH PEOPLE, ANY
STORIES?
DEVIN: NOT REALLY.
I HAVE NOT BEEN AROUND TOO MAN